go go go number one story in the world
dude number one story dude get to it all
right so basically you have
in europe you have the national leagues
where they play that's like premier
league la liga
syria that kind of thing you play you
have spain you have england you have
france
you have italy has their own league and
then you have a continental tournament
or a continental league it's called the
champions league and basically all the
best teams in every league the top four
teams from every league will all play
each other
in a cross national showdown called
called the champions league and it's
like the greatest arguably the greatest
sporting leagues like sporting event
outside of like the world cup right in
the whole world better any other
any other sport every year every year
more than any other sport more people
watching than any sport ever
i don't believe that's true religion
that's the best four meal one is more
uh-uh more people watch jake paul in
there
champions league gotta get trailer i
think but basically what happened is all
the teams that were making the most
money so it's like
liverpool uh tottenham in england
arsenal
uh another team in england oh manchester
united uh
barcelona madrid and then in italy as
juventus inter milan ac milan
basically all of them were like yo we're
going to form a super league [ __ ] the
champions league we're going to make our
own money we're going to stream our own
what about germany another german none
of the french teams went with it
that's the problem that's the rift
that's part of the drama so basically
they said look we're gonna make our own
league
because no one gives a [ __ ] about these
other smaller teams they're not paying
to watch them play they're playing to
watch us play
so we're gonna do our own league where
we're gonna make all of our own money
we're gonna stream our own games and
instead of
you know us playing each other every now
and again or maybe risking that we don't
make it because we lose to some lower
team when we lose out on 200 million
dollars to go to the championship we
lose in the group stage to some random
team
we can't risk it so we're gonna start
our own league make our own money we're
gonna play our games wherever the
[ __ ] highest bidder's gonna pay us
and we're going to make all of our own
[ __ ] all a lot of these teams also is
important to note in england are owned
by
american owners oh yeah like lebron owns
one of them shits
yeah he's like a part owner of liverpool
or liverpool and like
what his name john henry is the red sox
owner also owns liverpool yeah
vice chairman of the super league is
like cronky orleans like yeah
dodgers yeah so he's part of this new
league it's like a spanish chairman and
then three americans where you're like
too many americans on this board but
that's because there's dude they know
how to make money
the guy that owns the the holding
company that owns the buccaneers owns
man united
so it's like all the basically these
billionaires are like yo [ __ ]
the league [ __ ] the tradition of soccer
[ __ ] all that [ __ ] we're gonna make our
own money stream our own games
and [ __ ] the fans whatever we're going
to do it however we want to do it
so it's kind of like a like basically
like a mutiny or like taking over the
whole
tradition of european soccer by
billionaires that's the short version
you're the only real soccer fan here
tell me what's good about this what's
bad about it
i mean what's good about it from like
the
position of the clubs is that they're
able to then
control because basically like soccer
blows up in
korea for example because of manchester
united signs this korean player and it
blows up
this is a few years ago park park g
young or something oh
i mean probably i can but basically
that's the easiest
park yeah it blows up in in korea and
manchester united is like
that isn't it that's the first name yeah
so just said it yeah and he's like oh
yeah
so for example he said that like he
didn't say it
harkens her name you said it with the
energy of i'm correcting you yeah
park park i accepted that why did i
accept that [ __ ] i was like oh excuse me
yes
totally right liberal
but basically they're gonna be able to
control their own leagues they're gonna
be able to control their own games
they're gonna be able to make all the
money from it and it's probably gonna be
like benefit the players of those teams
in a way they might get a pay raise
and the clubs will be able to make more
money for the fans they'll be able to
watch these like
you know the best teams that exist at
the time playing each other more
frequently
that sort of thing yeah there's like
some of the the plus size to it or there
might be more residual
opportunities that are good yeah uh for
the clubs but the negative size is like
one it is like sort of like depleting
the tradition of soccer in europe so in
europe a lot of teams like aren't even
necessarily making a ton of money
like the majority of teams in england
aren't really making a ton of money and
they just exist because it's the
tradition of the town that the team is
in
so like in america a lot of the teams
like will make money mls all those teams
make money this is the thing that zlatan
actually brought up he's like yeah
like the mls makes money even though
it's not that big the level's not that
good all these teams are making money
in europe they just do it for the
tradition of the game the love of what
soccer is over there
and so doing this is basically going to
create way more disproportionate
advantage to those teams that are
playing in the super league because on
top of that they want to
not they want to take away the champions
league but they still want to play in
their national
like uh print premier league syria they
want to still play in like their
national english league
and then instead of doing champion they
do their super league exactly and
they're gonna make crazy money doing the
super league because they just don't
have to share with as many teams and
they don't share as many teams and it's
all the biggest games
and so then they're going to be able to
go back to their national leagues with
all this money and they're going to be
able to
trounce them even more so these other
random teams fulham or whatever like
that don't have the money that they do
are going to that wealth gap is going to
be even
greater and their argument is also like
every year in champions league that
no-name team has a chance for a
cinderella story to come in or play a
season in championship yeah less before
their relative team they won the whole
champions league and it's like one of
the most creative like craziest like
upsets in sports porto in
2004 yeah yeah okay so so it's like
bashing the tradition it's like [ __ ]
up the local smaller teams
yep it's why is this short-sighted it
seems to me like this is short-sighted
and it could have negative effects in
the future
i mean you don't want it too
disproportionately competitive league
it's it's it's directly non-competitive
yeah it's creating basically a monopoly
on soccer and making it not free
marketing
well soccer has relegation yes but to be
fair within their individual leagues
that's
kind of where it already is like for
example like real madrid and barcelona
are gonna be the top two teams no matter
what and then maybe another team like
sprout out for a little bit and then
they'll just buy those [ __ ] players
so it's like
when you watch la liga it's almost like
formula one
where like the winners have been decided
already
i kind of i don't think that's true when
when in our existence have
real madrid barcelona or atletico madrid
not been the winners of la liga i think
atletico
i think atletico madrid won like not
that long i just said that one of
one of those three i think he's saying
athletic goes not one of the big three
yeah i don't think they're going to the
super league like
there's been but still okay so with
formula one right there's like
10 teams two cars a team and you know
who the top three [ __ ] people are
gonna be and that's just what it is
there's nothing you can do about it
and that's kind of how things are in
soccer leagues as well in spain is more
so but like
england is less like that what about uh
france
france is even less like obviously psg
is like the epitome of like big money
oil and
sports and then what about germany
germany there's more fluctuation again
like there's always going to be like the
lakers and
right of the any league but yeah it's
much more it does seem like there's much
less parody in european leagues sports
team like the sports
formula one parity is like um like the
nfl anybody can win the super bowl in
any given year
oh yeah we're all kind of on equal
ground yeah the nfl is the most
yeah um and then it seems like europeans
even though their
government is much more about parody and
not letting people have too much
the sports they watch it's all just the
haves and the have-nots formula one
soccer whatever the [ __ ] else they play
who cares that's what makes champions
league interesting is that you have all
the best teams where like for example in
la liga there might not be
as much open market competition because
these three teams win every year
same with like uh in syria like juventus
has won the last seven
you know syria tournaments so like they
always win but in champions league
it's way more equitable because it's all
the best teams that are competing with
each other so i guess
what i would ask is like how is this not
a better version of champions league
because i mean on the one hand like it
is
affecting all the lower teams in those
leagues so like it's affecting the
actual quality of the play
in the other leagues telling the other
teams like go [ __ ] themselves so soccer
fans
just just so i understand
don't those teams already go [ __ ]
themselves because they can't make
champions league i thought champions
they could still go they could still go
into the champions league because they
have a chance
yeah oh it's top four yeah so okay it's
top four so then
this new super league is basically like
let's just do top two
they're basically just saying it's a
closed group oh not even baseball
that makes way more sense to me and why
it's frustrating my
because what i was thinking was like
dude the top two are already decided
always anyway with these leagues or at
least the top few is all the same right
but there's a chance you get a sneaker
that comes in there at four and then
they get the opportunity to play in a
much bigger stage maybe like lester city
was like this
nobody team that comes through five
years ago and wins the whole thing have
they been since
they've been great yeah they've been
competing super that money like floated
them
yeah exactly and it changed the whole
trajectory of the club and that's what
happens with a lot of these clubs is
that they'll do nothing have this crazy
showing get all this money and be able
to buy players and grow the club and
then the whole club flips
that's okay then i for that reason
the fact that like it's very difficult
but you can get there
i believe in the champions league and i
would believe in the super whatever it
is
if they had the ability to get in but
the fact that you're like closing it off
it actually reduces competition exactly
then it's a monopoly it was directly
and you take away hope but at the same
time like what happens in uefa in the
champions league when a big market team
like inter milan for example like
they didn't make champions league but
they know they're so much better than
some other players from other leagues
that are in that
champions they have to sit out for an
entire year
without those eyeballs without those
jersey cells for for that so for them
they're like
we're on so they don't want to on the
global side from a business perspective
am i
the you get to keep this is interesting
eyeballs on i'm more willing to watch
more of these like crazy matchups
between like uh real madrid and juventus
uh than than all of these other
champions league games this is really
interesting so what they're trying to do
is protect themselves
uh from a random year where they get
bumped out of the champions league and
they lose potentially hundreds of
millions and the streaming rights are
crazy like if they go to the champions
league final they could potentially make
upwards of like
three million four million so so i'm
looking at this 400 million yeah i'm
looking at this a little different i'm
looking at this from
this actually doesn't benefit uh real
madrid or barcelona this benefits the
team that barely makes it mm-hmm
what do you mean like so like let's say
the top four teams that make it in the
la liga are uh real madrid barcelona
atletico and valencia or something
right like this kind of really benefits
valencia
because they're like oh i'm locked in
i'm guaranteed that
valencia might not be in it but like the
teams are locked in that might not make
it some years like you were talking
about inter milan
they could lose 200 million so they have
a bad year yeah but
people might not want to watch the games
because all the biggest players aren't
in those leagues
so like okay we're not gonna like are we
gonna watch the champions league because
like
random you know lower level syria teams
are in or do we want to watch those
lower level serial teams play real
madrid
like it's those big money games that
people want to watch so by pulling all
the money out you basically just tell
the leagues like
yeah no one's going to watch you anyway
it's like if the the
lakers the knicks celtics
and whatever other big threesomes i'm
talking about like if you don't qualify
so for example he was saying like inter
milan just didn't qualify one year
and then the fact they didn't qualify
for champions one year they lost out on
all that money throughout the year
exactly but if you knew you qualified
every year because these were the teams
that were fixed and in there
now you don't have to worry about losing
200 million dollars yeah exactly that's
why they're interested that's why
they're making the supervisor yeah
right that now it's all starting to make
sense that's the expense of
the other teams and other leagues that
all of a sudden like their big fish are
out
i looked at it like uh barcelona and
real madrid are just being greedy when
in reality it's the team that
might not make it sometimes it's the
inner juventus knows they're going to be
in
but inner is like no this sounds like a
great idea because they could be
bounced out some years potentially
juventus as well yeah till they got
renault that's the same that's why a lot
of these english teams a lot of the
english teams i think like
right now there's like four or five that
are in the conversation but i think like
five more like yeah we would be in it if
we could
like they're like putting in bids to be
in it especially if you always if you
have a big fan base
that you want to say you're saying i
want to serve that fan base
year round so we're locked in i'm not a
fan of removing competition from sports
but how do you stop this from happening
so
a lot of people are trying to stop it
well uefa has sorry interrupt
this kind of already happens because
they do these scrimmages
have you seen this like like real madrid
will come here and play barcelona
in giant stadium yeah i went to one of
those they [ __ ] make so much money
and i'm sure that they're like
why don't we just always do this that's
the other piece of it is that they're
gonna start doing the games instead of
doing
you know tottenham versus manchester
united or even like liverpool manchester
united is a huge rivalry
instead of doing it in manchester or in
liverpool
let's go do it in saudi arabia we're
going to go do it in base wherever
they're going to pay we're going to do
it to where the highest bidder is which
makes it feel almost more like
like a money grab that is [ __ ] you're
not even doing it for the actual fans
that adore the team you're not going to
do it in the city that like it lives on
like tottenham for example is like one
of the poorest like suburbs of
london and it so much of the town
like sort of lives on the revenue that
those games bring in
like when yeah arsenal comes over to
play tottenham in tottenham's home
stadium like that stadium like
thrives the bars around it are going
crazy
oh yeah and so when you remove that it's
like you're removing a lot of the
sustenance even just for
local cities okay so there's crazy
pushback not only for the fans for the
reasons of
like here they see that their teams will
potentially be excommunicated from this
bigger picture right but also because
they rely
on the business that comes from this
right interesting so
there's a lot of like um football towns
in the way that we have like university
towns in america
yeah oh it's a college town college live
that for that exactly that thing wow
[Music]
for an american i mean they're looking
at probably like there's 300 million
americans we can still convince to love
like
super high-end soccer there's two
billion chinese people that are still
fighting for like who their teams are so
yes they're in acquisition mode dude
that's that's really weird that's what
i'm saying i don't see how you stop this
there can be uproar
there's gonna be this well what's gonna
happen right now that they're saying is
that they're
they're gonna try to uh uefa's needed so
much reform for so many years
but right now they're saying that they
might come after the players like if you
get traded to another team they're going
to try to penalize people within
champions league
even now but this doesn't what i
understand is like what happens if like
psg and some of the big french teams and
the big and bayern don't go in there
how does that do you know that yeah so
the thing with that like one the way
that they're gonna penalize them is
and again uf is not perfect like uefa
and fifa are both corrupt in their own
other ways but and which is arguably
like why they're doing this because they
weren't giving
like basically all these clubs were like
yo give us a guaranteed qualifier spot
in champions league
like you're making us like gutted out in
all these games like
just give us a guaranteed spot like
we're getting players injured like it's
affecting your bottom line because we
can't have our stars playing like just
give us a guaranteed spot it doesn't
seem corrupt
give us more money they're negotiating
on that end whatever but
basically they're saying to the players
hey because fifa
is its own governing body you wait for
his own governing body to say hey you
playing these games you can't play in
the world cup
you can't play in the euro and that is
the biggest stage and so all these
players are like uh do i go
play for the in beijing with real madrid
or do i go play
for spain in the world and so now
they're penalizing them in that way
and the reason why the french teams in
the german teams haven't jumped on is
one
to my understanding and i'm not positive
about this but the french teams have
invested
interest in uefa and that psg is sort of
like
in the way that like these other
billionaires are trying to corrupt
soccer and make their own league
i think psg is sort of like corrupted
uefa and you wait for
things like a french governance already
but like they have they're sort of like
in with uefa being like hey help us out
with this give them a like
and so you so psg is like no like we're
with uefa
and then i'm pretty sure the german
teams have
what they call the 50 plus one rule so
my friend david was bringing this down
for me he basically was like they have
the 50 plus one rule so basically the
german teams have what they call like
fan
trusts that have partial ownership of
the team
so because they have hackers yeah
exactly so they have this fan
trust and so basically the fans are like
it this obviously disenfranchised the
fans so the fans are like no we're not
doing it
so the fans are making the decision for
the german clubs right
they don't have the autonomy exactly so
they're preserving the german tradition
in bundesliga
to stay with their cities and stay in
their league
ah so yeah yeah it's kind of wild i mean
i wonder if this
could something like this happen you
think to uh american sports
kind of they don't have the
intercontinental like or like the
international
sporting games like that you know what i
mean but couldn't the nfl
i mean they're the most greedy owners
they're the most i don't give a [ __ ] the
six biggest teams in the nfl
be like yo we're just gonna form our own
league well that's what jerry jones did
right didn't he say
i'm selling my own rights oh like yeah
didn't he start this
jerry jones is like a big as shitty of a
gm as he is with football he's a [ __ ]
brilliant money guy
and apparently everybody thought he was
crazy because they used to just go to
cbs with the tv deals
and uh be like hey you know we'll just
take whatever and jerry
was like no we're not doing that and he
was like [ __ ] that break the deal
he was like pivotal in them saying hey
who's the highest bidder
you get nfl games and now that's changed
the league money
so much how much these guys pay like 2
billion a year is the most recent deal
for espn is paying for like [ __ ]
monday night football or something that
we don't even care about and i think
he went through and negotiated his own
sponsorships for his stadiums with pepsi
even if the nfl's with coke or whatever
like he doesn't give a [ __ ]
so if theoretically they want the nfl to
be a global game they want teams in
london
they want jacksonville to go to london
at some point there's a lot of people
hoping that happens couldn't they be
like hey they already play a game in
london every year
what if jerry was like hey we'll just go
play every cowboys home game wherever
the highest bidder goes well you could
do that
but you need a certain number of games
to sustain the league
you